und es geht direkt los mit trinken
grünen feiern jungs urlaub auf malle ja
doch für 13 kegel kumpel aus dem
münsterland endet eine partysause auf
malle in einem feuerinferno und im knast
sie wollten feiern und landen im knast
von mahle 13 deutsche tourist geführt in
handschellen 13 männer vom kegelclub
stramm am tisch und ein partyurlaub sehr
gründlich aus der bahn
mallorcas partymeile der ballermann hier
wird gefeiert hier wird getanzt hier
wird getrunken gerne bis zum umfallen
doch plötzlich das dicke schwarze
rauchschwaden ziehen am freitag über die
lieblingsinsel der deutschen
el arenal in flammen nur wenige meter
von der party meile entfernt eine
katastrophe für die besitzer der bar ein
ott mallorca die bar gehört einer
deutschen auswanderer familie
jetzt steht sie lichterloh in flammen
und am explosionen verdrehen und herum
und musste das penta hotel sein oder um
das war unsere größte angst ist dass die
hier gebaut und dann sind wir hoch
gewonnen
[Applaus]
er konnte nichts mehr machen
die 13 festgenommenen deutschen hatten
im benachbarten hotel la beach gewohnt
sie tranken gruiten feierten angeblich
auch auf diesem balkon laut zeugen
flogen getränke und zigarettenkippen
über die brüstung vermutlich landet
einer dieser glimmstängel auf dem bambus
dach der bar binnen weniger sekunden
steht der stolz der bayerischen
auswanderer familie trotz in flammen die
feuerwehr kam als üblich gedauert wir
selber haben noch mit teuren alles
probiert zu treffen
es dauert 20 minuten bis die feuerwehr
eintrifft ein mann erleidet eine
rauchvergiftung ein mädchen eine
schnittverletzung das lokal das familie
trotz erst im juni 2021 eröffnet hatte
ist zerstört auch das darunter liegende
bordell wird beschädigt ebenso ein
weiteres haus und das hotel der
kegelbrüder die 13 männer werden
verhaftet der vorwurf brandstiftung die
urlauber bleiben vorerst in u haft ohne
funktion
feuerinferno also auf mallorca auf der
lieblingsinsel der deutschen und wir
schalten auch direkt dorthin und zwar zu
unserer reporterin ari suhl eisdorf nach
mallorca und zwar genau dorthin vor der
feier ruine steht sie an diesem morgen
dort in el arenal so schönen guten
morgen wir uns einmal mit wie sieht es
setzt heute in dieser feuer ruine aus
genau wir stehen jetzt gerade genau vor
dem wiener hier auf mallorca villarreal
wie wir sehen ist hat geschlossen und
man kann sich gar nicht von der seite
gar nicht vorstellen wie das hier am
freitag gebrannt land aus dem ich hier
werden schon ein paar leitungen erneuern
man sieht da oben den rauch die
ausfuhren noch
hier sieht man wie es noch von der
polizei alles abgesperrt ist von dort
oben von dem balkon sollten
halt von den jugendlichen
auch das schild nach retten stumme
geworfen worden sein und es bleibt dann
hier alles nicht alle man sieht auch
hier gegenüber ist noch ein weiteres
hotel die menschen mussten evakuiert
werden
und es ist ja nicht nur sachschaden
entstanden sondern es waren auch
menschenleben in gefahr einer erhielt
ein mann erhielt eine auch ein mädchen
erlitt schnittwunden am buß und wir
haben es gerade schon gesagt die jungs
aus deutschland die dort eben den mal
urlaub feiern wollten sind ja direkt ins
gefängnis gekommen sind sie dort denn
immer noch was weißt du darüber
im moment wissen wir noch dass die immer
noch in untersuchungshaft
aber heute spätestens morgen wird dann
ein richter entscheiden was wird auf
wird ins gefängnis kommen oder sie
einfach nur eine spar eine geldstrafe
bekommen aber das müssen wir erst noch
mal abfragen bei der polizei alle super
ist ja auch da steht wirklich auch eine
existenz vor dem aus die ba hat eine
deutsche auswanderer familie gehört was
weißt du wie es ihnen geht plant sie
diese bar wieder ganz neu aufzubauen
ich denke mal schon nach die sagte
rohner zeit musste die ba erst mal
geschlossen sein im moment geht man von
anfragen von 150000 euro aus das wird
aber jetzt noch ein
wird ein gutachter noch mal
begutachten und bot wie die schaden
entstanden ist und ich denke mal dass
die dame dann das lokal wieder öffnen
wird und auch weiter betreiben wird
hast du denn bisher schon mit denen
sprechen können wie geht es ihnen jetzt
im moment noch nicht wir waren jetzt ist
dann da die ba hat wird ja auch noch
geschlossen aber wir werden auf jeden
fall versuchen mit der dame anzusprechen
um fragen wie es der zweite geht